in the Wild Wild West days Dodge City
days of the Western American frontier we
had tremendous problems up until really
the early 1900s with the banking system
because a bank was basically a storage
place for money
you took your money in and when you put
money in a savings account in a bank you
were depending upon that bank to not
steal it to not miss manage and not go
broke and if they loaned out all the
money and nobody repaid the loans the
bank went under and all of the deposits
were gone they were loaned out in the
form of loans and people lost everything
that they put in a bank and so if the if
there was ever a question of the
solvency of the bank a question of the
way the bank was being run there would
be a run on the bank and people would
run in and get their money out because
they knew there was some money in there
and if they got theirs out it didn't
matter because somebody wasn't going to
get their money if the bank collapsed
and of course a run on the bank pretty
much ensured that the bank collapsed if
you remember it's a Wonderful Life there
was a run on the bank and in the movie
in the old black-and-white movie from
Christmastime movies right and that was
on the Savings and Loan or the bank in
law or the lending and Loan or whatever
they called that particular one but it's
the same concept and of course we ran
into the same thing heading up into the
Great Depression and the government
decided to stabilize our banking system
to form the FDIC and so banks have to
pay into the insurance fund to insure
that one of when one of the member banks
fails that the depositors are covered
and so there's not runs there's no
longer a run on the bank but if you put
money in a bank in a foreign country you
don't have that unless that foreign
country has some kind of a banking
system
that's our insurance system that ensures
the stability of that lender or that
exchange and if you put money in a
foreign currency meaning if you buy the
foreign currency if you use your dollars
to buy euros or your dollars to buy yen
or your dollars to buy whatever other
currency there is the peso whatever
whatever it is then what you are doing
is you're saying that you're gonna play
the field you're gonna speculate that
that currency is going to become more
valuable than the dollar then the
American dollar you're betting if you
say put the money in pesos you're saying
okay those pesos are going to be that
they're going to buy more than dollars
will buy in the future and so if I put
two dollars into pesos today later I can
take the same number of pesos and cash
them out for ten dollars and that's
trading in currency it's what you're
doing and so you're buying the yen or
you're buying the peso or you're buying
the Euro or whatever and you're betting
really when you're doing that you're
speculating gambling in a very real
sense against the American dollar
because there's no rhyme or reason for
this because all of a sudden a
government can decide to flood its
currency and in America they always we
always call that quantitative easing
where we just dump currency into the
market and it makes the dollar it
dilutes the value of the dollar and when
they do that and they try to do it at a
pace that it doesn't create big ripples
but other countries are not nearly as
sophisticated and so they can destroy
the value of a currency a currency only
has value to the extent that someone
else wants it so for instance in my
bookshelf in my office I have some paper
money in there with Saddam Hussein's
face on it no one wants that money
except as a keepsake a souvenir but I
can't take that to the gas station and
buy gas I can't pay my water bill with
that and even if I were in Iraq
couldn't trade it for a meal no one
would want the Saddam Hussein paper
money it has no value it has lost its
currency it has lost its value because
no one else will trade for it it never
really had any value it was paper
the only value it has is that is the
promise that someone else will trade for
it legal tender and so we carry green
paper around in America and we say
that's money but it's really only money
because someone else will take it and so
that's why the Iraqi Dyne are these
people run around buying the Iraqi dinar
is such a stupid idea and it's such a
scam not because I think IROC is bad or
not because I'm politically mad about
this it's none of that it's a simple
economic fact you have a war-torn
country with an unstable government and
you're buying their currency this would
be stupid you're going to lose your butt
and so today it comes out that one of
the big exchange companies for Bitcoin
has crashed and so bitcoin is very
unstable at the moment and looking like
it's not going to make it and what is
Bitcoin bitcoin is a currency on the
internet it has no value except to the
extent someone else will take it from
you as value just like that paper has no
value except the extent someone else
will take it
so bitcoin is the Iraqi dinar of the
internet and I know intelligent people
who while they're intelligent are not
wise that have put a bunch of money in
Bitcoin but it's a really good way to
turn a million dollars into nothing to
play in unstable currencies that there
and here's what you have let me say what
bitcoin is it's www it's the wild wild
west you're back to the Western banking
system because all of the sudden one of
these computer nerds just flips a switch
the whole freaking thing's gone
it has no value I just got completely
ripped off and it took them down and so
the little hipster techy guys are
sitting in front of the building with a
sign that says where's my money well
honey you never had any it's not real
money because it's not got it's not a
stable currency that has any kind of a
system that backs it that has any kind
of a system that protects well I've made
a lot of money at Bitcoin you can make a
lot of money trading dirt to somebody
else trading dirt until people catch on
that dirts not a good idea to trade you
can trade gravel out of your driveway as
long as you can get away with it and so
just cuz you made some money doing it
doesn't mean that it was a bright idea
and so I'll go ahead and you know I got
all your rocky Dyne are people and all
you gold people all pissed off at me so
let's just go ahead and add you Bitcoin
people to the mix you're stupid you're
gonna lose your money be pissed at me
you shouldn't have put money in
something wacko like that people money
and handling your personal investments
is not difficult you put it in things
that are tried-and-true that have been
around forever you don't have to risk
your dadgum life fortune in some made-up
computer game and that's basically what
you're doing here no backing it's the
wild wild west it's gonna turn on its
head and you're going to lose your but
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
you